on en vient à cette contre-offensive qui
montre bien l'ascendant récent de Kiev
sur le terrain mais aussi les craintes
de Moscou à Kerson région fraîchement
annexée par la Russie les habitants vont
être évacués par les hommes de Vladimir
Poutine écoutez notre envoyé spécial en
Ukraine Mélina Huet
encore beaucoup d'incertitude dans le
sud de l'Ukraine ce que l'on sait c'est
que le chef de l'administration
d'occupation de cette région enregistré
hier un message qui a été diffusé sur
telegram un message vidéo dans lequel il
exhorte je cite tous les habitants de la
région de Helsen qui souhaite se
protéger des frappes de missiles
sous-entendus frappe ukrainienne à se
rendre dans d'autres régions d'autres
régions sous-entendu russe alors on
pense évidemment à la Crimée qui sert de
base arrière aux forces armées russes
pour progresser dans le sud de l'Ukraine
péninsule annexé en 2014 on le rappelle
mais pas seulement puisque l'agence
d'État russe tasse a affirmé que
certaines personnes pourraient déjà
arriver ce vendredi à Rostov qui est une
ville non loin de la frontière créer une
ville russe impossible de confirmer à ce
stade ces affirmations on rappelle que
la région de ridson elle fait partie des
quatre blast dont Moscou à revendiquer
l'annexion au début du mois et cette
allocution intervient dans un contexte
très particulier qui celui de la reprise
de territoire par l'Ukraine dans le sud
donc Harrelson 400 km² de territoire
récupéré en l'espace de quelques
semaines selon les autorités
ukrainiennes et alors même que ces
autorités hier ont largué des tracts par
avion dans les régions occupées du Sud
pour exhorter les habitants à fuir le
plus rapidement possible soit dans des
territoires sous contrôle Ukrainiens
soit le plus à l'Est possible de prendre
un sac avec des affaires chaudes de
l'eau des vivres cela pourrait annoncer
une véritable offensive sur la ville
elle-même de Helson attendue depuis
plusieurs mois